in this video i'll be breaking down how
exactly i was able to go from having
zero knowledge of aws to getting five
aws certifications all within the space
of 18 months i'll be sharing the exact
resources i used what my exam strategy
was and what advice i have for people
who want to get aws certified in the
shortest amount of time whilst
maximizing the knowledge and experience
gained from the certifications a big
thank you to today's sponsor squarespace
but more about them later in the video
now if you're new to this channel
welcome i'm an associate solutions
architect working at amazon web services
and i make videos to help people get aws
certified build their technical skills
and land a job in the cloud computing
industry so if that sounds like
something you're interested in please
make sure you give this video a like and
subscribe to this channel to stay
updated now let's just jump straight
into it this is the four step approach i
take when studying for adb
certifications step number one scoping
step number two active listening step
number three getting hands-on and step
number four reinforcing scoping is all
about getting an understanding of what
you need to study to pass the exam and
then creating a high-level study plan if
you're anything like me you probably
also struggle with motivation when it
comes to big goals like getting an aws
certification this is why before
studying for each certification i put
aside one to two hours to understand
what the exam requirements are what
resources i should use and how much time
i need to dedicate each week to my cloud
learning journey for example the first
thing i did when i was preparing for my
solutions arctic associate exam was to
read through the official exam guide
every aws exam guide outlines the
individual weightings of the main topic
areas which i found really helpful after
that i selected the resources i plan to
use to prepare for the certifications in
my case i purchased this udemy course
taught by stefan and practice exams
created by tutorials dojo finally i
blocked out two to four hours on my
calendar each day to study so that i
could reach my goal of passing the exam
within one month now after all that
scoping and preparation is done the next
step i take is active listening this is
where i start watching videos from the
uw course and take notes of the key
points i like to hand write my notes
because i find that it helps me remember
things better this step is quite simple
watch your video write some notes watch
another video write some more notes and
then at the end of each study session
review the notes you've written in order
to consolidate your knowledge at this
point of the video you're probably
wondering okay lucy what about resources
do you recommend now after spending over
200 hours studying for 80 certifications
and sitting those exams here are the top
resources i would recommend click pause
this video is brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business if you're looking to
create your own website get started with
the best-in-class website template and
customize it to fit your needs you can
browse from different categories to find
a perfect starting place you can also
sell your products on an online store
whether you sell physical or digital
products squarespace has the tools you
need to get started with selling online
every squarespace website and online
store also comes with a suite of
integrated features and useful guides
that help you maximize prominence among
search results head to squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to squarespace.com tech
with lucy to save 10 of your first
purchase of a website or domain so when
i was studying for aws certifications i
tried out a whole bunch of video courses
and different instructors and here are
the top five i would recommend stefan
marek on udemy super concise engaging
and easy to understand adrian cantrell
focuses on the details provides clear
explanations and teaches you not only
how to pass the exam but also provides
important concepts for real-world aws
projects neil davis concise easy to
understand great video courses and
practice exams john bronzo tutorials
dojo best aws exams i've come across
super detailed explanations and finally
adab skill builder it's completely free
and there's learning material to help
you get aws certified if you'd like to
check out any of those courses i have
the link to them in the video
description below now that you've
watched a bunch of videos for the
certification exam and have written down
notes the next step is really to get
hands-on by playing around with the aws
services the good news is the video
courses i recommended all come with
interactive tutorials that help you
navigate through the aws console and use
the services however i recommend taking
this a step further and gaining even
more experience through aws workshops if
you head to workshops.aws you will see
over 100 free aws tutorials going
through a couple of these workshops will
help you become more confident when
sitting your exam because you would have
had actual hands-on experience the final
step to studying for edible
certifications is reinforce everything
you've learned through the video courses
and hands-on workshops by doing practice
questions i think on average for every
certification i did around 300 to 400
practice questions that's how many it
took for me to get ready to sit the exam
because there are so many different
types of questions they can ask
especially in the harder ones like the
solutions arctic professional exam my
biggest tip is to make sure for the
questions you don't answer correctly go
back to the video courses to review the
content that way when it comes to the
real exam you'll have had a chance to
make sure you fill in the gaps in your
knowledge now as i've mentioned earlier
i have spent over 200 hours studying for
aws certifications and sitting aws exams
because of this i'd like to share with
you my top pieces of advice and my
learnings throughout this whole
experience first of all make sure you
understand your why why are you studying
for the certification in the first place
this will help you stay motivated and
consistent make sure you study smart not
hard split up your time wisely between
video courses hands-on exercises and
practice questions book your exam before
studying for it this will help you work
backwards so that you can block out time
in your calendar to study just be kind
to yourself everyone starts off with
different levels of technical experience
so don't compare your progress with
others and remember it's okay if you
don't pass an exam on the first go and
finally subscribe to the channel to
learn more about how to get a job in the
cloud industry alright so this brings us
to the very end of this video thank you
all so much for watching this video
honestly took me a really long time to
make because i was trying to figure out
how to best give advice on studying for
adobe certifications so i would really
really appreciate it if you can give
this video a like and i'll see you soon
bye for now